[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity justice in America now with the
Democrats collusion conspiracy exposed
as a hoax it looks like a new round of
party infighting is on the horizon
because while Democratic leaders like
Nancy's Pelosi and Majority Leader Steny
Hoyer are signaling against impeachment
that's not stopping other rank-and-file
lawmakers from pushing their own agenda
and even refusing to fully accept
Muller's no collusion finding take a
look you accept the specific conclusion
that there was no criminal conspiracy I
accept that conclusion for now but I
think there's a need for continuing
investigation there are clearly offenses
in future bull offenses and there may be
impeachable offenses there may be
censurable offenses
do you accept the special counsels
conclusion on that point agree but again
we need more information
I believe impeachable offenses have been
committed and I believe it's worthwhile
to put in histories files what this man
has done in impeaching but I don't think
it's gonna happen politically the base
wants impeachment they want to beat him
it badly that was mr. Cohen who I had
the pleasure of serving with in Congress
Wow and he gets worse because twenty
twenty candidates senator Elizabeth
Warren is joining the impeachment course
tweeting that the house should quote
initiate impeachment proceedings against
the President of the United States end
quote and echoing her our congresswoman
Rasheeda Talib in Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes all despite Muller findings of no
criminal wrongdoing by the president
joining me now for reaction is Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter and Congressman
Mike Turner of Ohio and Andy Biggs of
Arizona to the three of you thank you
for joining us here I always start with
a Mike Turner you're in Ohio but you're
also on the Intel committee they're
singing the tune of impeachment for
goodness sake what's your reaction to
that well you know Jason this is part of
the process of trying to deal Ajith
amides a Republican president we saw
this of course with george w bush's
election where they allege that he
colluded with his governor brother of
florida to steal the election they took
that case all
the US Supreme Court and now with Trump
they claimed he colluded with Russia to
steal the election and then used as you
kept saying Hillary Clinton funded
material to get surveillance over the
Trump campaign but you know in the
heartland right here in Dayton Ohio the
headline that hit everybody's doorsteps
today was no collusion with Russians and
that certainly is has a big impact
that's not a presidential tweet that's
the headline it's gonna make it
difficult for people like Adam Schiff
who's going around saying that there is
collusion but now we see their shift now
they want to go from collusion to now
say they want to go after the president
because of his opposition for their
efforts to pursue him for crimes he
didn't commit I don't think people are
gonna buy it I think they understand
those four words of know collusion with
Russians to hopefully be the end of it
well I'm glad the headline in Ohio got
it right because the Washington Post and
the other ones did not and Sarah Carter
I want to get your your impact on this
senator Warren she's one of the leading
contenders out there she's saying she
wants to have impeachment how do you
think that's gonna go well I don't think
it's gonna go well for her I mean this
is this is gonna backfire it's gonna
backfire on the Democrats the American
public is really sick and tired of this
they know now based on this report no
collusion
there was no obstruction now we're
hearing that in the report you know that
even Don Magan his story changed
multiple times
that's a president Trump's former lawyer
and and so there was even a you know
little section in the report that
specifically stated you know his story
was very confusing so as far as
obstruction is concerned there's no
obstruction there and this is coming
from Senate you know from Elizabeth
Warren who was basically called out for
lying on her card and you know calling
herself an American Indian and and we
know that she's not this is gonna
backfire in her it's gonna backfire on
the Democrats Adam Schiff as is another
one that's been very much pushing this
collusion delusion narrative
consistently at President Trump and I
think the American public's canna tire
of that and I'm going to tell you
something else
the most important thing I believe Jason
is that coming up when the
investigations start on the part of
Attorney General William bar and when
the investigations are
filled that Michael Horowitz has been
conducting over the past year it's
really gonna backfire on them now Andy
Biggs here congressman on the east side
of the Phoenix Valley there Mesa and and
whatnot in Arizona a very important
state in the 2020 politics I mean do the
Democrats that you serve with in the
house that they really love Mike Pence
that much do they really want to be the
president all right that are they just
on this crazy train to who knows where
with all this impeachment talk well I
think they're on the crazy train I think
there's a significant number that are
very skittish and wisely so they don't
want an impeachment process they know
it's going to hurt them especially those
forty districts that we call swing
districts that that support Trump that
maybe a Democrat picked up last a
midterm election but I'll just tell you
what when Adler's subpoenaing these
documents and he's going forward I think
they're doing a market test to see if
they're able to keep the middle that
they're hoping to get by if they go to a
full impeachment I think they really
want to do a full impeachment they think
that the the base is gende up enough to
do it but I think that there's some wise
heads or some politically minded heads
when Pelosi and Steny Hoyer who are
saying hey this is going to hurt us if
we do it but I think Nadler and you know
Nadler and you know Schiff yeah they
want to go forward to just test you see
that can we stand there yeah well you
had more than 60 Democrats already
signed up for impeachment before he even
cut through the report exactly
congressman Turner you serve on a very
important role on the Intel committee
you see day in a day out behind closed
doors Adam Schiff I mean how does he
have any credibility I don't understand
why he even has a security clearance and
why he's even on the committee at this
point what is very troubling certainly
all of the Republicans on the committee
called for his removal as chair of the
committee not just because of the Mis
statements that he's made where he's
come out and said that he saw evidence
of collusion where clearly there was no
evidence of collusion and now the model
report
you know without question settles that
issue but the issue is is that he is
using the committee solely for the
purposes of pursuing President Trump
with his vendetta against him you know
our adversaries are Russia China North
Korea and Iran and we need to be looking
at the ways in which they're impacting
our national security and as long as
Adam Schiff continues to believe that
the greatest
threat to this country is Donald Trump
our adversaries are getting a pass and
our committee needs to get back now
you're right there is a huge opportunity
cost by not focusing all the other true
threats to this nation I've got just 30
seconds left Sarah Carter where did this
where does this go next well we know
where it's going it's going into very
deep investigations into the genesis of
the origination of this investigation
into President Trump I believe there
will be indictments I believe people
will be held accountable for this and
that is why I thank Jason that any type
of impeachment impeachment proceedings
or hearings of that nature are just
going to backfire on the congressman
Biggs last word do we actually see
people in handcuffs held accountable for
the Genesis and the abusing the FISA
Court system we better because the
American people demand that and I it's
if we don't it's just another crime in
history thank you all three of you for
joining us on this beautiful Friday
night